[Music]
we have time for one question when you
die is it just lights out I hope so I
really hope so yeah yeah it's over thank
good and I think you just go in the
ground and if they would stop putting
people in boxes if they would just put
them in the ground you would you would
nourish the soil right and somebody else
would having a bet yes you know these
people you know getting their heads
frozen trying to come back to do what
what are you gonna do like you're gonna
come back like how much time like Ted
Williams just has his head frozen that
wasn't his choice like how long is that
head gonna be frozen before they they
have a cure for having no body sure
you're gonna be like I mean I already
have a generation gap when I do a
college gig I just can't imagine coming
back like thousands of years later and
you know you're not hip on music people
are making references to yeah that's
like the you know the French and Indian
War 500 year like you have no idea what
anybody is talking about you know not a
levitate you can't like communicate
without speaking instantly you're going
right to the circus
[Applause]
[Music]